population just over 300 000 is in
southern poland traditionally it's an
industrial and mining city not known for
its beauty in recent years it's been
increasingly used as an open-air gallery
the kachevitse street art festival puts
off-the-wall art on the walls of drab
apartment buildings for instance this is
the fourth year the festival is being
held
the festival keeps artists working in
and around katowice for 10 days though
some projects take longer
sergi radkovich has been at work on the
first part of his planned series on the
seven deadly sins for two weeks now
this one is sloth he doesn't work out
the idea for his painting until he's on
site
i need always to saw the wall uh because
it's like public place and it's as
all walls have the structure have the
like it's natural material i need to saw
it and understand
what this
what needs this wall
even with all the turmoil in his home
country ukraine he doesn't want his
current work to convey any political
message he's creating it in poland for
polish viewers outdoors and free of
charge
it's a public place where you can make
it for people for to to solve their
reaction to communicate with them to
collaborate with them to try to
manipulate with them it's it's nice
because it's real life it's you can
connect have some connection it's it's
cool
the first street art festival here took
place in 2011 well-known artists from
the world over have taken part the
spanish artist arith for example his hen
is now something of a festival trademark
the image was even brought to life for a
promotional video
another street art star is spanish
artist essief he painted this light
switch on a prefab block in 2012.
it doesn't have to be on my building but
still it's a good idea
i always like to ride my bike around
town during the festival and look at
everything it's great
it looks brilliant especially the hen a
great idea
now i think of it as the tunnel of fear
the city is much more colorful than it
used to be
the grey around us is disappearing
the festival includes an exhibition on
the history of street art in poland it
had its beginnings in the 1980s but it's
more popular now than ever before
it started as a form of protest against
the communist regime
street art in this country is closely
tied to the history of sorry
the major polish opposition movement of
that time
particularly
started showing up in the late 1980s and
became well known
for example
to this day many people in poland see it
as a kind of icon
a total of 14 artists are taking part
this year funded mostly by the city of
katowice
sasha kormas also from ukraine works on
his abstract statistics he's well aware
that in a few years it will have faded
or been painted over
you and me have some short life
and every every people who live in this
beautiful years also have limited in
life so it's normally if your art piece
also have limited time it's not a
problem for me it's not a problem for
people i don't think about you must make
something special for all times
next year katowice will be celebrating
its 150th birthday and to mark the
occasion its 5th street art festival
will add yet a little more color to the
city once again